We have a voicemail number and that number
is two.
One nine, two, David P, I don't know where
people are getting these ideas, but here is
someone alleging that the David Pakman show
and the Kyle Kalinsky show are receiving DNC
funding, which is as untrue as it is laughable.
And I'll tell you why in a second.
Hi, David.
My name is Michael and I was just curious
because I've heard from some progressive outlets
that yourself and uh, individuals like Kyle
Kalinsky have been taking large funds from
the DNC to know whether or not this is true
and if so, why do you do it?
Um, another thing I wanted to know is, um,
what are your thoughts on a libertarian progressive
Alliance?
Okay.
I don't care about libertarian progressive
Alliance.
Um, no, we're not getting any DNC money.
You know, I, I don't know if the DNC supports
media outlets, um, that are not like the big
corporate [inaudible] corporate legacy ones.
But if they did, I don't think they would
support the progressive ones where the hosts
have said they're voting for Bernie Sanders.
Something tells me that that's not the, that's
not the wheel house of the DNC.
Uh, to start throwing a throwing cash around.
On the bonus show today, we will talk about
Elizabeth Warren's reaction to Michael Bloomberg's
NDA pledge on those nondisclosure agreements,
we will talk about a Daredevil flat earth
or who has died after attempting to launch
himself with a homemade rocket.
And we will also talk about the Supreme court
taking up
a religious Liberty dispute on the issues
of same sex marriage and foster care, all
of that.
And more on today's [inaudible], the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].